got married in prison  and just take us through the ceremony  i got married a couple of times i got  married like five times in prison but i  only got married married one time like i  made my own wedding gown and everything  with the white sheets they give you they  found out that bombijo was messing  around with me  they pulled him to the side they told  him you got 30 days to make up your mind  either you want to be with him or or are  you going to  get out of being one of us or you're  going to stop messing around with him  one of the other 30 days sitting aside  you can't decide to stay with me  it's like it's like the new notebook how  long did that marriage last that  marriage lasts like two years whoa  that's pretty significant  yeah but then he got transferred it's uh  that's what i was going to ask you so  technically you're still married to him  if ben b  that's that's prison mary it's not it's  not like it's all marriage it sounded  pretty real to me